la Pologne on l'a vu à ces derniers
jours terre d'accueil aussi pour ces
populations des civils vont donc se
mettre à l'abri dans ce pays voisins
pendant que d'autres
Ukrainiens font le chemin inverse
inverse Magdalena chaud devenir vous
êtes à chez Michelot côté polonais merci
d'être avec nous en direct Magdalena
installé depuis des années dans le pays
vous l'avez vu vous les avez suivi vous
leur avez donné la parole à ses
Ukrainiens qui font le chemin inverse
pour rentrer en Ukraine défendre leur
pays
oui je suis juste devant la gare où il y
a des Ukrainiens qui arrivent
directement de le vivre ou de ça et de
l'autre côté il y a aussi des Ukrainiens
qui vivaient déjà en Pologne qui ont
décidé de partir en Ukraine pour
rejoindre les combats donnant les
chiffres selon le garde-fontières ils
ont dit que sans à 30 000 personnes ont
été déjà partis en Ukraine pour le jeu
en les combats et c'est ce qu'on sait
aussi il y a des réfugiés bélairus qui
qui vivent en Pologne depuis des années
qui ont décidé de former en bataillon
qui va réagir aussi le combat en Ukraine
pour se battre contre le duo location et
Poutine merci beaucoup merci Magdalena
Magdalena chaud de venir en direct
depuis la Pologne